what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to start up
the series eight episode run season one
of Reacher how do we come here well we
got some requests I've been interested
in this show because it's cultivated
quite a fan base and that surprised the
heck out of me so I was like you know
what this has been on my Q you might as
well convert it to the channel it
follows our criteria of what we decide
to react to on the main page and our
patreon as well so ladies and gentlemen
if you go ahead smash that like button
like this guy's biceps who's ever
playing Jack retronome who this guy is I
I don't think I've even seen the trailer
for this I just know he's tall and of an
appropriate build as compared to Tom
Cruise it actually fits the description
of the book this is what I've heard
that's all I've heard and also be sure
to subscribe click the notification Bell
because we do want to make it through
the rest of these episodes as well
full-length Reaction watch along is
where you sync up with your own copy of
Reacher available for our super sexy
rejects over at our patreon page but
because this is the first episode the
first full-length Reaction watch along
is available for the public so you'll
find a link in the description box and
pin comment but also at our patreon we
cover a bunch of stuff over there
exclusively with reaction highlights and
watch how long is included let's see
what all the hype's about let's see if
it lives up to oh the talk
foreign
good shot
someone's mad die
now who's gonna know that dude got shot
wasn't it just pouring rain a second
okay it still is okay
depending on what part of the country
you're in you know you can walk 10 feet
and it'll be not raining anymore
or maybe it's symbolism that it's a
brighter day now that Jack Reacher has
arrived sorry
how am I supposed to
God damn money I'm on his side
the hell you won't
he wants to save the cat moment
listen man
I'm just having a bad day
that was cool all I had to do is look at
it until he would change his expression
one bit that was cool black and peach
pie
best you're gonna find in Georgia but
they all say that kind of looks like a
super buff Sam Worthington yeah sure
let's get it done
[Music]
oh my
that's Jack Reacher's diet
is always bye
reach your water they get caught
Andy left a 40 tip hands behind her head
hands behind her head
interlock your fingers Flex those biceps
you're under arrest
for murder
oh snap he was just on a bus if you step
over here I can process you I'm not
asking sir I'm telling but don't worry I
won't kick your ass unless you make me
I like her all right what is your name
Sasquatch don't talk
Jack Reacher zip ties cuffs didn't fit
them
that's why you don't skip four arms 212.
this looks like some kind of foreign
deal
World War II metal French
I'm Chief detective Oscar Finley
I was informed you were read you're
right so you know you don't have to
answer
confirmed victim was male 30s big guy
no idea yet
problem getting prints off the body's
swollen fingertips I love how you can
see he's processing all this information
maybe your court appointed attorney will
get you to open up
I don't need a lawyer so far run on his
Prince has been clean but something
could still turn up
but there's no Facebook Snapchat
Instagram him
he's not an influencer he's a teacher
people How to shed those pounds retired
army what if I'm thinking I'm sitting
across from a man who doesn't mind
killing and who has the knowledge and
training to murder someone and cover it
up
you'd be right
where'd you get that conclusion three
men dropped this body shooter was
someone who knows Firearms well he also
knew enough to pick up his brass this
wasn't a first timer this was someone
who knew how to conduct a quiet
effective kill nice nice you're also
looking for a psycho who'd beat up a
body postmortem someone completely
unhinged
something wrong
no
your psycho isn't suddenly going to be
rational enough to know he has to hide
the body in your meticulous shooter
isn't going to do a sloppy job with
roadside cardboard
well the third guy is so worried about
getting out of there he grabs some
nearby debris and just lays it across
the corpse
I got off the bus from Tampa and walked
to town I asked the driver to do me a
favor why on account of blind blink
Legend has it he died in margrave long
time ago I figured I'd learn a bit about
him I like music
[Laughter]
medical examiner puts the victim's time
of death at around midnight last night
this morning it's last night until 11 59
and 59 seconds and then it becomes this
morning
[Laughter]
laughs
running down a phone number found in the
dead guy's shoe means I'm gonna be here
for a while
foreign
companies are slow responding to
warrants like it they're kind of
figuring out the case together yeah
unlikely Duo father and I will unpack
you too go and meet the base kids this
is home now hopefully for a while and go
make friends
it's gonna be like Army Shazam
Soldier that's the way to the beach
yeah
that's five bucks for the looks about
your jacket yeah
I'm big for my age
just like you're ugly for your age
oh you could be ugly anytime
let's get some Stephen King bullies
going
you don't have to do this
it's my fight
that's cool
we're taking a ride got hit on the phone
number yeah the phone company stepped it
up you invited me over to chat but never
asked what crime I just wanted to get
you over here so we could talk
[Laughter]
male shot to death
he was found with your number written on
a paper scrap in his shoe
I did it
however it doesn't believe him he did
what was his name
I don't know you killed a man you don't
know yeah that's right
self-defense
in the back of the head terrible story
I'm not about to rehash all the details
you are my second annoying interrogation
today
a double barrel shotgun blast right to
the face
yes and then burnt the body
smart yes I did smart
I love this detective not sure if I've
seen this actor before but yeah this
lead detective is great
[Music]
come with me
not until you let these zip ties come
off get the boss cutter it's okay
I got it of course you do
that's good don't want to get ridden up
for littering in the police station you
guys recycle
awesome
I was just cleared one guy lied about
killing another guy that doesn't clear
you good town of murdering even when he
confessed nothing happens to you
bars on bars this guy
might still have information to share I
don't
Stevenson does he and Hubble were
looking at each other
they looked at each other they held eye
contact for a full two Mississippi
you're always so confident in your
theories as confident as I am that you
went to Harvard you recently divorced
and you quit smoking in the last six
months nice you're stubborn you have a
chip on your shoulder you don't care if
your co-workers like you a guy like that
doesn't go to BU he goes to Harvard
yes you're also about 40 which means you
did your 20 at Boston PD to get your
pension so you can afford a proper
Southern soup but you still look like
black Sherlock
[Laughter]
holmese as for the smoking when I broke
down the three murderers back there you
started to think you had the wrong guy
the water in your class moved a bit
we're not on any major fall lines a
major Lane was bouncing onto the table
you know you know you need him he'll
solve the case oh sure it's Holmes
Versus Holmes Stevenson my office
try not to look so guilty right now the
show is pretty cool all I know is that
at midnight he was nowhere near that
Highway a couple in the trunks no he
cheat on his wife no he's a family don't
answer his questions he's not your boss
right
do you have money problems
I don't know what to do
[Laughter]
the only way you'll know why Hubble
confess is if he tells you yeah well
maybe a week in a lockup will motivate
him
let me know what he says
now Chief Morrison wants you in custody
till we know for sure that all six foot
four of you was on that bus from Tampa
six foot five we keep extra large Cuffs
in our lock box
es tall inventory is watching ring
they'll stealing first five minutes he's
in there
it was nice talking to you
ship them this is really engaging yeah
hasn't even been any action scenes but
it's a lot of deductive action scenes
but a Samoan fella come to here last
year met dealer and scrubs made up
special
I would hate to take off my shirt next
to that guy yep
drop them drawers bend over and spread
no
the victim I'm suspected of murdering
was shot by a handgun that would measure
four inches by six that weapon's not
fitting inside me or any other human
being without sending them to the
hospital
[Laughter]
so if you think you can perform the
inspection without getting seriously
injured go for it
break those fingers with your butt
cheeks otherwise check the box on your
clipboard
you can inspect him I don't care yeah in
fact please inspect it
let's get a room together yeah he can
protect him he'll be partners and I like
the movie the one time I saw it
but this show makes me go this must be a
good book yeah all right it does a good
job of capturing the mystery of who this
guy is really well too what's going on
we're not with the guys awaiting
arraignment where were the lifers what
do you mean life first I mean people
sentenced for Life yep what
wow
oh you have to survive
you got a first visitor there she is no
no
give him shoes baby
you heard me get my shoes a good little
good girl
like glasses too get my glasses
that's messed up yeah that's mean the
shoes I can abide but
yeah there's just one more thing I want
from you
oh my
[Laughter]
God go
see you're in my house Fatso and you
didn't ask permission
so you and your friends can leave now
where they can carry your fat ass out in
a bucket nice I take the bucket now I'll
count to three
do you know what you're talking to one
two
that's brutal
and efficient you owe us a pair of
glasses
those will supplement those lenses yep
that's cool I wanna I wanna Jack Reacher
in my life
it's got the shades now
the only thing keep me alive in here
in big trouble
no I'm not a criminal
currency manager
yeah whose currency are you managing my
boss is Promised if I disrupt their
operation in any way they'd
they'd nailed me to a wall
hey
cut my books off and make me eat them
it's a veil threat
I gotta take all that time and effort
it's with this specific group here I'm
gonna hit the head that guy's head
sweet bathroom fight kill him with a bar
soap I love bathroom fights break
someone's head on a toilet
on a sink anything
oh
what is going on
we need protection
if you boys knew what's about to happen
to you you'd leave now
so I'll give you to the count of three
one
wow oh my God
yes
oh
wow that was violent kill or be killed
you don't shank Jack Reacher
wait
my report says you were placed upstairs
why are you and Jen popular
that's where the guy put us
it's much calmer here
this guy just wants to chill
I think he just wanted a vacation
divorce and quitting cigarettes it's me
um
I'm just uh
I'm just dealing with the tough case of
missing you
got Reacher's military record from DC
West Point graduate Silver Star defense
Superior service medal Legion of Merit
soldiers medal Army Commendation Medal
Bronze Star
and a Purple Heart
for wounds sustained in the bombing of a
Marine's barracks in Kandahar woof got
the license plate too Jack Reacher's the
murderer
return to active duty 32 hours later
despite having shrapnel remains of a jaw
bone removed from his abdomen whoa
what is this man what in God's name is a
guy like that doing in margrave it's a
guy like that doing in jail
Jack Reacher solving the case for you
Jack Reacher did the murder because
nobody's good enough to outsmart him now
so he just has to outsmart himself
[Laughter]
give in to Temptation I would have just
thrown them out yeah having them at all
is kind of a guarantee
I'm more curious why whoever you work
for wants me dead and gone from last
night's baby
you set us up in genpop
he played off like it was some kind of
innocent mistake but it was intentional
guys in the shower I need me as a person
to take out damn
something bad's going down in my grave
and I don't need to be a part of it
famous last words
shitty sandwich did look good though
my wife should be here soon
I don't give a
any idea your car could use lip
uh taking a shine to him
he's been in prison a long time thank
you some love
imagine love reachers like Greyhound
confirm that's their Tampa station two
nights ago
that way you could've been a more grave
in time to kill anyone so you cleared me
but how does a guy who confessed walk
away
but he knows that Hubble's line so
Hubble's probably dead huh Roscoe's
actually my first name
cool so what's your last name chicken
and Wok
that's a very unique name I'm on the
next bus out of here I feel bad about
the margrave Welcome Wagon running over
understandable I was going to apologize
within a really dinner but if you're not
sticking around okay oh do it but I'm
gonna need some new clothes first
um we got a moralsman chop in town
a proper shower too what about money
pensions wired to a Western Union each
month don't you miss your family they're
all dead
except for my brother Joe
he's a good guy where's he an upcoming
episode
Joe's the killer damn it I'm here
because of blind Blake read some article
about Blake said he played his last show
in margrave and that's where he died so
you just go wherever you want whenever
you want
everyone's always jealous so I'll check
out the town for a while see you in a
bit sounds good
and don't go getting yourself rested for
murder again
that truck
everything's suspicious that truck at
Coca-Cola sign that pickup it's not just
a sponsor
[Music]
the truck the truck's back I'm trusted
but a Blues fan might be able to tell me
a bit about blind Blake's time in
margrave most surprise you know blind
Blake
Mr Richard
Foundation takes care of Margaret that
statue out there his grandsons I met he
gave Klein a sweetheart pickup truck
that does Klein a Junior and his Bug
House cousin Dawson I call him
trouble
do you want to dance to Tom burrito with
me hell I'll dance I'm talking to your
beauty
talking the guy in price of your boots
better hair cutting expensive truck he
lets you sit shotgun in
you want me to lead her
I'm not much of a dancer more of an
academic and a reader you found his
mansion
reading something interesting just this
morning about some charges brought
against a major Jack Reacher in a small
village outside of Baghdad a very
serious nature but charges that somehow
disappeared like grains of sand and
unforgiving desert
ah you are a reader what's your back Mr
Richard
you threw him off his game yeah it's
like I'll be sticking around another
body was found the brush 40 yards from
the first one same caliber bullet can't
say I'm not disappointed I was looking
forward to spending time with you before
leaving
huh well I don't know if we're going
anywhere just yet did Hubble talk when
you two were locked up
no
you're not going anywhere
my alibi clear maybe I need to bring in
a forensic expert to confirm it was you
and maybe you need to cool your heels
back in Warburton and while we get that
done open next two or three weeks just
say you need his help this second guy he
was shot in the back of the head while
running away but his legs kept humming
for a few more feet before his brain
told him hey buddy you're dead Gamo
killer just left him there no ID on him
Killers an investigation Details Matter
he's my first murder so please tell me
you know who did this
his fingertips were compromised by
dermatitis reaction
so swollen prints wouldn't come out
clean until I drink some of the fluid
we're waiting for the results what whoa
um
is he new on the force or
first victim was allergic to latex
his Dental Works off because he had his
teeth fixed wherever he was living at
the time
broke his right arm when he was eight
had it set in Berlin
had his tonsils taken out of 10 in Soul
travel the corpse
oh
[Music]
he knows this man
seems like it by his expression
we were wrestling
I pinned them against the stove
I didn't know my mother just turned it
off is that Joe is that Joe that's how
my brother got this score
what so Joe is the killer so it's just a
coincidence you and he are passing
through the exact same photo town at the
exact same moment in time I don't know
when's the last time you saw Joe a
minute ago in the morgue I'm being
straight with you
well no wonder Sharon left you oh
okay my wife's name
no enough that aged well I know you're
not the kind of guy to beat up on
somebody half your size without good
reason he's giving me a reason yeah well
I know people
and you've got condos
Joe did not look much better looking I
did not keep that reach or hairline just
thinking maybe my brother told me about
blind Blake for a reason thinking I'm
supposed to do something about it
I guess I'll find everybody responsible
for you yeah Kill Them All
ah title card damn that's a great oh
that's a great first episode yeah man
it's riveting
it's crazy when I believed the most
I was the one I believed the most was
that
Joe's bad guy
predictable for an unpredictable show
sure sure
who could give me this run for my money
is my own brother yeah yeah that was
good that was really good yeah I didn't
catch any of the cast name
I will only know them by their
archetypes and uh certain personality
traits and physical descriptions sure
and I only know Harvey Guillen it's
Harvey Guillen he was the coroner at the
end he's on what we do in the shadows
and was in Puss in Boots too that's who
you know yeah not you Guillermo well um
yeah I mean oh wait we've got seven more
episodes to get through so keep this
relatively short yeah uh I was really
impressed with this I thought it had a
great Rhythm and a good energy about it
I've I often find myself the characters
like Jack Reacher going
what is the threat here what is a way to
make someone like Jack Reacher
feel
like he's an actual danger because it
just seems like he's like he's awesome
like he's awesome like he's so awesome
and like I don't I don't know if any guy
like him truly exists but he's sorry
he's so incredibly Wally he's perfect
and you know like a physical threat and
an intellectual threat to mental game
threat you can't seem to get a a one-up
on this guy ever
and so to have this
mystery come come to his doorstep here
with his dead brother and to be
confronted with it where you can feel
the emotional toll I think that's what
makes it fascinating when you're with
what they pose as like the things that
could hinder him is being stunted a
little bit by uh the triggers of certain
pains within which I find really
interesting I don't know if that's like
the full direction of where the show's
gonna go I imagine that there will be
some actual physical threats or he's
going to whoop ass left and right for
seven more episodes uh but I like that
situation where the guy brought up the
the clothes the buried case in Baghdad
and you could see that there was there
was a disturbance in the force in that
moment and then of course with his
brother as well you you can you can feel
that pain and that kind of pain that can
like motivate him or it could or maybe
throw him off of his game and so I
really I really liked a lot I never
plays him I don't know his name and I'll
I'll try to learn it by the end of the
series but I thought he was great you
know uh like I don't
I wasn't interested in the show when it
first came out I only became interesting
because people kept asking about it and
and I I like the first Jack Reacher
movie and I never was in love with it I
really hated the second one that was
awful not good that was an awful film
not a good movie
um
and I'll say you know
for what I while I like Tom Cruise a lot
in them in that first movie there's
still like a variation of Tom Cruise 100
and watching this you can really see
kind of how it was molded to being Tom
Cruise yeah yeah well a much bigger
teeth grinning sure Jack Reacher is not
really that here and I've heard the
comparisons of why book readers were
upset with Tom Cruise's casting
like a lot of it came down first to the
physicality of him but I really love
that they did here was the
reintroduction I I don't know who this
actor is maybe I've seen him in
something before and I'm just not
recalling at this moment uh I thought he
brought a lot of weight to his
performance and you know both physically
and mysteriously because when he's first
introduced I do like the imposing figure
the build that he is when he first walks
on the screen it's awesome
but then they don't lead with action and
that was the probably the first thing I
noticed was how they're not trying to
sell you on who he is by by level of
action at all even though the first
thing you that strikes you is this guy's
massive it's like he's a massive dude
and it's cool to get a dude who is like
that massive but is superiorly
intellectual totally and you don't
really get the hybrid of that I can't
think of too many characters like
nothing I'm sure exists uh I'm sure I've
seen something that I love with that
kind of character but you don't you
don't really get that on screen it's
usually one or the other and to get a
character like that here where
everything that well why whatever my
vague recollection is that I've heard of
people who complained about the Jack
Reacher movie who were fans of the book
I see that that's really been brought
over here and as someone who hasn't read
the book I felt like that works much
better like I found this really engaging
from beginning to end yeah as compared
to what I remember in my experience of
the first movie which was like cool in
the wash and whatever
um this was uh I could see I could see
how people like I would I would continue
watching the show if I just wanted to if
I just stumbled on the pilot yeah
absolutely and I think yeah it strikes a
really nice balance both with the
character and just in the with the tone
in general it's been a little while I
feel like since I've had something like
this in my viewing diet where yeah you
have the obvious action elements the
obvious you know badass stuff but it
does feel like much more than the Tom
Cruise movie like you are in the world
of a novel of a crime novel and of that
sort of lyricality that space that air
that kind of permeates everything and
yeah like setting the stage here like
there are a lot of tropes you know like
ah Drifter rolls into town just at the
time you know a murder happens and he's
always cool and collected but yeah I
thought they played nicely on his
character where yeah you meet everybody
else because they're agitated by how
calm he is and then by the end of the
episode you do get a couple moments that
rile him up one in a subtle way and then
one in a very overt emotional kind of
way and I can only imagine we'll see
more flashbacks of him and Joe growing
up and things like that but yeah just
the way they displaced everything the
way that they introduced all the
characters uh Finley and Roscoe
especially I thought were really you
know nice
additions and and the things that they
are not editions but just like you know
nice um you know important yeah like
main supporting presences that are going
to help flesh this journey out that much
further and yeah having him have
this you know like timid Banker guy
along with him and expecting him to be
the body of it like there were just like
a lot of nice twists and turns that
don't feel too much like uh like they're
you know look how clever we are you know
like it does just genuinely draw you in
with a good amount of
it feels I don't know something about
the way that they've orchestrated it
here feels lived in because he does have
all that mystique and yes he is like a
lot more smart and articulate and
well-read than you would expect but he
feels like a real guy in his portrayal
of that and even his silence in the
first parts of the episode where you're
just watching him kind of process
everything and you're watching him speak
with his eyes and his thought process as
really nicely tailored I feel like
across this and the tone the mood the
way they capture the town the way they
use the music and the thread of his you
know interest in blues and the reason he
came to uh margrave in the first place
this is all yeah just like really
colorful and interesting that's fun yeah
it's a fun show sure it's like genuinely
fun yeah and this is one of those shows
that I I could see being a true
worldwide appeal and like what I mean by
that is I I can imagine going to
like my in-laws house I would see like
the older folk watching this show yeah
but I get all these young karate he's
gonna join too like yeah it is it is one
of those shows or you you can definitely
see like the people in the Midwest and
stuff just watching the show everyone
yeah yeah yeah anybody can get into it
it seems like yeah because yeah it's not
particularly it's not it's not
commenting on that so on on like the
town it doesn't seem like it's looking
down on the people of the town or
anything like that you know and yeah
it's like the kind of hero yeah anybody
could get behind and it is a fun mystery
to try to solve as well uh-huh they they
have a good mystery of float and yeah
like the performances Finley cop Maine
cop yeah Finley's good really really
good and he the psychological profile on
him was a great way to get some
Exposition on the character that's I
think that's like smart Exposition
because it tells you who that character
is and it also tells you about Jack
Reacher at the same time
foreign
like this was cool because yeah there is
action and the action is cool it is
satisfying when it happens but I think
they did wisely to both draw that out
and and create tensions to the when the
action pops off it really hits but
there's a lot that does feel like just
as intense but it's just people sizing
each other up and kind of examining
little Clues and you know sparring back
and forth mentally and I think that's
another thing that's impressive when you
can really make that vital I mean the
show's cool and got swag and like
um even though for YouTube we got to
remove As Much from the music swag the
the music the music fits it well like
the music doesn't tell me how to feel
like you just kind of that's sort of
just the vibe in the aura it just feels
like you're there yeah yeah it's cool
and I like the small towns a lot like in
real life I really love going to small
towns so having this show set in a small
town I think is really neat and
unpacking uh murder mysteries are more
fun when they're in a small town setting
it's more personal oh yeah one small
town murder that's that's that you know
everybody appeal that I feel like right
now it's just where's the small town is
it in Scandinavia it is in the heartland
of America you're like that's your
flavor but yeah it's it's like classic
but also it's got enough of the fresh
unique elements too and it's shot cool
and it's R-rated yeah yeah they throw
down man like that's that was a a bloody
fight in a way that's not in your face
but also where you do feel the impact
and and yeah yeah it's nicely Jack
Russell remember was PG-13 right yeah
I'm pretty sure it is yeah but I believe
it's PG-13 we're yeah this is this is
all right it's not like super hard R yet
there were a couple of moments that were
like wow that is really R-rated well
yeah and I could I could imagine if
there there will probably be future
murders and I can certainly imagine them
getting into the autopsy the the
coronary side of it too you know and and
that you know grossness that comes with
that yeah and there's a lot of respect
to about the way it's shot you know I
thought it was actually really smart to
not even show Joe's face just to keep it
more about the presence of Joe's dead
body and keep it on Jack Reacher's
expression I thought this was really
cool and that was really really cool
yeah it was pleasant I really enjoyed it
yeah a lot from beginning to end it was
very very enjoyable and very engaging
didn't let me go suck me in and didn't
let me go all right guys well what did
you think about Reacher is it just
called Reacher I think so all right hey
they wanted to really distinct divide I
was 100 not that short guy uh yeah okay
this is called reach room what did you
guys think about Reacher did you enjoy
it leave your thoughts down below be
sure to subscribe leave a like you can
catch us on patreon and hey let's send
this with a patreon
Chris wamoth I feel like Chris Wham off
is the perfect person to shout out for
Reacher because what we know about Chris
is the guy is this Samaritan yes
the right word he is he is a Samaritan
finding people helping out when he
doesn't have to often in small towns yep
yeah actually
yeah because he's really accurate we
don't need a it's apparently
our way through here this is actually
really all true yeah the only the only
thing I'm not sure about is if you're
you know supremely buff you know but I I
feel like you probably take good care of
your body given what I know about your
disposition so you're probably at least
fit he's been arrested before for
helping out dude that's the way to get
arrested all right here's a good reason
to be arrested just like could you could
you stop making the rest of us look bad
we're gonna detain you now yeah man yeah
that's it you're at the Jack Reacher of
our patreon page we have found the
character to call you from now on oh
yeah the Jack Reacher of our patreon
you're the peach pie of of our dessert
here at the at the super sexy reject Hub
super sexy p-jack tub and uh and hey I
mean if you were watching our backs I
would never worry I would never lose an
ounce of sleep in my life because I
would feel so safe and secure just
knowing you're out there
you know I hope you wander through La
sometime and get arrested for trying to
do too much good and then we can bail
you out and then finally feel good about
ourselves and then you can make that up
to us by upping your pledge
because we don't have enough to bail you
out
how much bail costs in Los Angeles
I don't
know
Jack reach around yeah what's that that
is a film I'm working on right now
that's what I've heard of it yeah I I
waiting for your script notes
gonna be a really rich and narrative
adult film all right
[Music]